[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24 el
presidente de estados unidos joe biden
rindió un sentido homenaje a las 500 mil
víctimas de kobe 19 en ese país el
mandatario hizo un llamado a dejar las
diferencias partidistas y luchar contra
la pandemia en conjunto esto mientras
avanza rápidamente el plan de vacunación
a escala nacional
el ayatolá alí jamenéi líder supremo de
irán desafía nuevamente a eeuu a los
organismos internacionales al anunciar
que su país se puede comenzar a
enriquecer uranio al 60 por ciento
cuando los pactos acordados no permiten
que supere el 20 por ciento el anuncio
tiene lugar cuando hoy entra en vigor
una ley que impide las inspecciones de
la onu a las instalaciones nucleares
iraníes sin previo aviso
y en una nueva jornada de
manifestaciones contra la junta militar
que tomó el poder en mianmar fueron
realizados los actos fúnebres de uno de
los manifestantes fallecidos durante el
fin de semana de otra parte la justicia
de malasia no pudo evitar la deportación
de casi 1000 ciudadanos birmanos que
estaban en situación migratoria
irregular en ese país del sudeste
asiático
muy buenos días estamos en vivo desde
los estudios de france 24 en bogotá en
colombia soy santiago lópez gonzález
bienvenidos eeuu superó la barrera de
las 500 mil víctimas mortales por kobe
19 el presidente de ese país joe biden
encabezó un acto conmemorativo y un
minuto de silencio en memoria de las
personas fallecidas el mandatario
también instó a los estadounidenses a
dejar de lado las diferencias
partidistas ya luchar en conjunto contra
la pandemia marina sardina nos cuenta
más
banderas a media asta velas y el
replique de las campanas en honor a las
vidas perdidas por el cob y 19 en eeuu
el presidente demócrata joe biden y la
vicepresidenta kamala harris rindieron
un solemne homenaje en la casa blanca
cuando la nación supera la trágica cifra
del medio millón de decesos
es lo máximo
hoy pido a todos los estadounidenses que
recuerden recuerden a los que perdimos
ya los que nos dejaron atrás pero
mientras recordamos mientras todos
recordamos también pido que actuemos que
permanezcamos atentos que nos
mantengamos socialmente distantes que
usemos mascarillas que nos vacunemos
cuando nos toque que el taxi
eeuu epicentro de la enfermedad mundial
marca un sombrío hito las
estadounidenses han fallecido en un año
por la pandemia que durante ambas
guerras mundiales y la guerra de vietnam
juntas
si bien los estadounidenses son el 4% de
la población global representan el 20
por ciento de los decesos totales por
coronavirus en el mundo y cuentan además
con más de 28 millones de contagios
muchos intentan ahora buscar respuestas
a estos datos que reflejan una falta de
unificación nacional para contener la
enfermedad durante el último mandato de
donald trump
eso no explica como un país rico y
sofisticado puede tener el mayor
porcentaje de muertes y será el país más
afectado del mundo creo que eso no
debería haber ocurrido
aunque y no y no creo que sea ya sabes
todo donald trump o todo esto y aquello
es una combinación de cosas y
ciertamente la falta de implicación en
la muy muy alta cúpula de la dirección
pese al avance de una campaña que ya ha
vacunado acá
20 de la población las autoridades
proyectan más de 600.000 muertes para el
1 de junio el fabricante de aviones
estadounidense boeing solicitó dejar en
tierra a los aviones boeing triples 7
que están equipados con motores pratt
and whitney 4000 como el de la aerolínea
united airlines que recientemente tuvo
que regresar a tierra al presentar
problemas en una de sus turbinas qué
significa este anuncio para la industria
aeronáutica se lo preguntamos al señor
carlos san jose el es vice decano del
colegio oficial de pilotos de aviación
comercial de españa señor san josé
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 y comienzo por preguntarle qué
significa este anuncio hecho por boeing
que deja a más de un centenar de aviones
boeing triples 7 en tierra
bueno pues es una reacción muy rápida
tanto del fabricante como de la
autoridad nacional de eeuu
efe que han paralizado la flota hasta
que tengan completado una inspección a
fondo del funcionamiento de estos
motores concretos y es una muy buena
noticia la rápida respuesta tanto del
fabricante como de las autoridades los
boeing triple 7 ya llevan varias décadas
en operación ya han demostrado ser un
avión de largo recorrido muy confiable
para las aerolíneas pero los primeros
indicios de esta investigación apuntan a
una posible fatiga de algunos de los
componentes de ese tipo de motores en
particular nos plantan whitney 4000
quien se puede decir al respecto
bueno estos momentos el órgano
competente en eeuu que la ntsb ha
abierto una investigación para
determinar las causas exactas
de estos problemas y creo que todos le
debemos un respeto a sus profesionales
están investigando y guardar las
conclusiones para cuando termine la
investigación porque estoy seguro que
encontrarán las causas concretas de
estos señores san josé que impacto tiene
este anuncio hecho por el fabricante
boeing en tres escenarios que le voy a
mencionar para las aerolíneas operadoras
del triple 7 con estos motores
particulares los plátanos wind y 4000 el
segundo escenario para boeing que está
haciendo frente a la pandemia que dejó a
mil millones de aviones en tierra y que
estaba saliendo de la crisis que desató
el boeing 737 max y el tercer escenario
la industria aeronáutica en general
bueno para todos los que participamos en
la industria de reuters de los afectados
muy bien nos enumerado
este tipo de fallos pues tienen un
efecto y lo que hay que señalar es en
primer lugar el excelente trabajo que ha
hecho la tripulación de estos aviones
para conseguir que no haya víctimas y no
tengan consecuencias y en segundo lugar
la rapidez de las autoridades y del
fabricante para solucionar estos
problemas tenemos que recordar que por
mucho que avancen las innovaciones
técnicas en las terminales los aviones
estos adeudos años fallan y lo
importante es que esto falsa reconozcan
que las tripulaciones estén entrenadas y
tengan la experiencia suficiente para
hacer frente a estas incidencias y las
autoridades sean lo suficientemente
potentes como para investigar las y
corregirlas y a partir de ahí garantizar
que este es el medio de transporte más
seguro para los pasajeros
claro que sí señor sanjosé a lo largo de
la historia hemos visto que este tipo de
incidentes dejan valiosas lecciones para
la industria aeronáutica
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros en france24 haber explicado
este tema a nuestra audiencia en américa
latina' vamos a cambiar de tema cuando
se espera que en irán entra en vigor la
ley que pretende limitar las
inspecciones de la onu para conocer
detalles de la actividad nuclear en la
república islámica el ayatolá alí
jamenéi el líder supremo de ese país
anunció que irán podría enriquecer
uranio hasta un 60 por ciento esto
teniendo en cuenta que el
enriquecimiento de irán según los
acuerdos internacionales no podía
superar el 20 por ciento el anuncio
también desafía a eeuu y a los
organismos internacionales que buscan
acercamientos con el país asiático para
restablecer ese acuerdo nuclear firmado
entre irán y cinco potencias mundiales
catalina gómez ángel nos da más detalles
en el siguiente reporte desde la ciudad
de bagdad en el vecino irak
las palabras del líder supremo de la
revolución ayer en las que dice que irán
podría enriquecer uranio a un 60 por
ciento para su programa de energía
nuclear pacífico como ellos lo llaman
también tienen que leerse en ese momento
en el cual tanto a eeuu como los otros
países firmantes e irán están en un
momento en el cual podrían recuperar el
acuerdo nuclear y así están intentándolo
por la vía diplomática sin embargo el
líder supremo les recordó que ellos no
están buscando armas nucleares que así
lo sabían eeuu como israelí que si
hubiera querido hacerlo lo hubieran
intentado hace muchísimo tiempo esto
sucede en un momento cuando irán se
retira hoy de ese protocolo adicional
del tratado de no-proliferación lo que
significa que los inspectores de la
organización internacional de energía
atómica no podrán hacer visitas
relámpago a estas instalaciones
nucleares pero lo que sí lograron
negociar durante el fin de semana con el
director de esta organización es que los
inspectores sigan en iran y puedan
seguir haciendo visitas esporádicas sin
embargo no en la misma dimensión que lo
hacían antes
tampoco irán tendrá acceso a esas
cámaras que están ubicadas dentro de las
plantas nucleares aunque sí tendrán
acceso a esas grabaciones y en los
próximos tres meses logran llegar a un
acuerdo y continúan las protestas en
mianmar contra la cúpula militar que
tomó el poder en un golpe de estado en
la jornada de hoy fueron realizados
también los las honras fúnebres de uno
de los fallecidos durante las protestas
del fin de semana en la ciudad de
mandalay y de otra parte el g7 condenó
estos actos de represión y pidió la
restitución de los derechos básicos para
los ciudadanos de ese país mientras que
en malasia una corte local intentó sin
éxito evitar la deportación masiva de
unos mil ciudadanos birmanos que estaban
en situación migratoria irregular
álvaro cordero nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
y miles de birmanos continúan desafiando
a la cúpula del ejército que rigen el
país desde el primero de febrero su
objetivo es que los militares devuelvan
el poder que se tomaron tras un golpe de
estado
no quiero que nuestro país sea gobernado
por los militares porque tendríamos
miedo de salir y protestar contra ellos
bajo este régimen pero estamos
protestando a pesar de tener miedo aún y
vergara abajo
las protestas se han recrudecido en los
últimos días en total han fallecido
cuatro personas algo que ha hecho que el
g7 se una a la oleada de condenas al
régimen militar durante este martes se
celebró un entierro multitudinario en la
ciudad de mandalay de donde era una de
las víctimas asesinadas por un disparo
este fin de semana
me siento muy triste por perderlo
perdimos al refugio de nuestra familia y
necesito seguir adelante con el resto de
la familia
aunque el ejército niega la represión
cada día se restringen más derechos y en
las últimas horas se prohibió el uso de
la palabra golpe en los medios la
cuestión birmana alarma a la región y
diversas ongs intentaron frenar una
deportación masiva de más de 1000
birmanos desde malasia una corte
prohibió la repatriación alegando que
entre los afectados hay refugiados y
perseguidos políticos pero a pesar de
todo el gobierno la efectuó
y nos vamos hasta el sur del cáucaso en
georgia el líder opositor nicanor mendia
fue detenido por la policía
antidisturbios de ese país después de
estar 17 días atrincherados en la sede
del partido movimiento nacional unido
meliá fue privado de la inmunidad
parlamentaria que tenía a petición de la
fiscalidad nacional que lo acusa de
organizar disturbios que terminaron en
un intento de asalto al parlamento
georgiano en unos hechos ocurridos en
junio del 2019 en los que cientos de
personas resultaron heridas
matías arráez tiene los detalles
este martes las autoridades georgianas
cumplieron su palabra y detuvieron al
opositor ni camelia en la sede de su
partido mientras tanto en la calle
militantes se enfrentaban a los policías
es una imagen sin precedentes para
cualquier país democrático cuando un
número tan grande de policías irrumpe y
las fuerzas especiales irrumpen en el
edificio el principal partido de la
oposición para detener de forma
totalmente ilegal al líder del partido y
de la oposición
melià al líder opositor es acusado de
incitar a la violencia en las protestas
callejeras de junio de 2019 una
acusación que él ha rechazado por
completo el delito que se le imputa
podría llevarlo a una pena de hasta
nueve años de prisión
mercedes siempre así
en ningún caso pueden impedir que el
pueblo georgiano amante de la libertad
proteste este es el final este es el
final del régimen
los regímenes terminan así no mantendrán
el poder con el apoyo de estas fuertes
fuerzas especiales
la orden de arresto hacia el opositor
provocó la dimisión del primer ministro
jordi bancaria
la semana pasada el lunes el parlamento
de georgia nombró en su lugar al
ministro de defensa iraquí cáribas billy
quien ya había ocupado el cargo entre
2013 y 2015
amigos míos quiero repetir que en el
menor tiempo posible una de mis primeras
tareas y prioridades será restaurar el
orden constitucional en el país para que
nadie esté por encima de la ley este es
un nuevo capítulo en la crisis política
provocada por las elecciones
parlamentarias de octubre pasado que
según la oposición podrían estar bajo la
sombra de fraude
y en américa latina' las autoridades
argentinas difundieron la lista de las
70 personas beneficiadas en el proceso
de vacunación en ese país un caso que ya
es conocido popularmente como las
vacunas baby en la lista está incluido
el presidente alberto fernández parte de
su equipo de trabajo también el ministro
de economía martín guzmán y hasta el ex
presidente argentino eduardo duhalde
asimismo el listado también cita nombres
de destacados dirigentes políticos de
argentina empresarios y hasta
reconocidos periodistas
el consejo de seguridad de la onu
celebra este martes una cumbre de
líderes mundiales para debatir las
implicaciones que tiene el cambio
climático para alcanzar la paz mundial
un tema sobre el que los 15 integrantes
de este consejo tienen opiniones
completamente diferentes dicha sesión
fue convocada por el primer ministro
británico boris johnson y será realizada
de manera virtual coincide también con
el anuncio de la reincorporación de eeuu
al acuerdo de parís de cambio climático
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
en france 24 siga con nuestra
programación buenos días
[Música]